[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité armez vous de
patience et de persévérance si vous
devez renouveler vos pièces d'identité
avant cet été les files d'attentes
s'allongent depuis la fin de la pandémie
comme à toulouse où nous emmènera la
rédaction devient occitanie ils ont
choisi leur instrument et la culture
pour soutenir leur pays des artistes
ukrainiens se produisent sur plusieurs
scènes de france dans le sud ouest et
dans la sarthe les caméras de la dépêche
du midi et de lmtv sarc ont pu suivre
ces artistes en scène pour la paix et si
vous faisiez un barbecue sur l'eau vous
en rêviez peut-être c'est désormais
possible en gironde grâce au barbecue
bateau c'est son nom il ne découverte de
télé7 la chaîne du groupe sud ouest en
fin de journal et puis nous prendrons la
route des montagnes avec des vaches
vosgiennes quand entamé leur
transhumance pour la saison estivale un
moment toujours important et attendu
comme nous le montrera les caméras de
vosges télévision
le baccalauréat à peine débuté les
vacances d'été se prépare déjà et vous
êtes visiblement nombreux à vouloir
partir à l'étranger cette année après
deux ans de vacances marquée par les
restrictions sanitaires
attention tout de même si vous devez
renouveler vos pièces d'identité les
délais d'attentes s'allongent depuis le
confinement à toulouse par exemple les
rendez-vous s'étale sur plusieurs mois
seule possibilité en cas d'urgence
vérifier chaque jour les disponibilités
et les désistements un reportage d'anne
argué pour vyas occitanie
prévoir des vacances c'est bien mais
avec un titre d'identité à jour c'est
mieux car le délai de prise de rendez
vous et de trois mois aujourd'hui dans
les mairies c'est la course comme ici à
colomiers tout le monde veut pouvoir
partir en vacances et j'ai vu que l'été
était très long il y en a depuis le mois
de janvier j'ai eu rendez vous l'emmenez
j'espère avoir le passeport rapidement
un pour partir en vacances très bientôt
le 23 mai on m'a dit que c'était six
semaines mais bon j'espère la voir plus
vite ils sont six agents à gérer entre
50 et 60 demandes de renouvellement de
titres par jour et environ 50 retrait la
mêlée de colomiers a engagé un cdd
supplémentaires et tente de trouver des
solutions pour réduire les délais
d'attentes on envisage d'essayer de
réduire justement la durée du créneau de
20 minutes à 15 minutes pour pouvoir
octroyer des fins proposer des rendez
des créneaux supplémentaires aux usagers
en tout à toulouse environ 400 rendez
vous sont pris chaque jour des délais
alourdi suite à plusieurs conséquences
il ya une confinement qui a qui a
entraîné
un certain nombre de reports au fait de
renouvellement de passeport des usagers
et fermetures de peau de frontières
aussi nous avons également le
renouvellement de la nouvelle caste
entité qui est sorti qui entraînait une
influence aussi les demandes au niveau
des services administratifs marlène
schiappa annoncé hier soir un plan
d'urgence pour réduire les délais en
augmentant le nombre de dispositifs de
recueil dans certaines communes
le phénomène inquiète tentes ils durent
de nombreuses personnes des femmes
principalement sont victimes d'étranges
piqûre depuis plusieurs semaines en
france lors de leurs virées nocturnes
si les plaintes se multiplient après des
sorties de boîtes de nuit les raisons de
ces faits restent pour l'heure inconnues
dans la loire plusieurs victimes ont été
recensées sans conséquence grave pour
leur santé les responsables
d'établissements s'organise démultiplie
des mesures de prévention comme vous le
voyez sur ces images de nos partenaires
de tl7 les professionnels de santé sont
aussi mobilisés écouter ces quelques
conseils sur les bons gestes à adopter
si vous êtes victime vous même de l'une
de ces piqûres propos recueillis par
marie lise pariot et eloïse gerenton on
sait pas ce qu'on a est ce qu'on a eu en
fête en boîte de nuit donc notamment ce
qui a été injecté donc il faut
absolument aller directement aux
urgences et se signaler aux urgences
pour qu'il puisse faire une prise de
sang en général il ya un traitement
préventif qui va être instaurée
notamment un traitement préventif du
sida qui va être instaurée pour pour
plusieurs jours et puis soyez prudent
donc si vous sortez vous amuser avec le
retour des beaux jours louis giscard
d'estaing était l'invité jeudi matin de
l'émission face aux territoires sur tv5
monde le vice président de l'uwe dei et
fils de l'ancien président de la
république a notamment évoqué le sujet
des élections législatives à moins d'un
mois désormais du premier tour écoutez
ce qu'il a dit s'ils voulaient de notre
position c'est que dans l'ue des iae et
d'indépendance donc pour nous c'est le
critère déterminant nous avons déterminé
notre position en conseil national et à
une très très large majorité nous avons
décidé de soutenir au premier tour
d'élection présidentielle valérie
pécresse cette position n'était pas
partagée par l'ensemble de l'ue dit mais
vous la regretter un peu ou pas ah non
ne nous considérons que nous étions dans
une cohérence complète nous avons et si
on revient sur l'histoire la vème
république
après que mon père
député jeunes députés indépendants et
paysans avec antoine pinay a fait partie
des premiers gouvernement du général de
gaulle sans être gaulliste dont kylie a
chez nous cette idée très claire que
nous souhaitons apporter une valeur
ajoutée dans les territoires on y
reviendra peut-être et aussi sur le plan
politique parce que nous ne sommes pas
dans la majorité présidentielle et
monsieur macro l'émission face aux
territoires avec louis giscard d'estaing
est à voir ou revoir sur les sites
internet des partenaires de l'émission
ouest france nice matin et vingt minutes
le reste de l'actualité marquée
évidemment par la guerre en ukraine
depuis presque trois mois désormais en
france les événements solidaires se
multiplient un peu partout comme à
toulouse où un concert était organisé
par des artistes ukrainiens une étape
dans la ville rose avant une tournée en
europe est de récolter des fonds pour
leurs compatriotes restés au pays un
témoignage et des images de manon aussi
du journal la dépêche du midi sur place
l'idée est venue tout simplement parce
qu'on voulait dire merci à tous les
citoyens européens
de la part des artistes ukrainiens
authentique pour l'aide et pour la
solide et solidarité qu'ils ont avec
notre pays
c'était mon rêve devenir un prince avec
un concert et je voulais chanter l'amour
mais finalement je vais chanter
j'ai pas choisi d'être la chanteuse de
la résistance c'était le destin
est si triste et inquiet des artistes
ukrainiens aussi présent dans la sarthe
danse macabre c'est le nom du dernier
projet né du dac théâtre de kiev une
troupe très très connue là-bas et exilé
en france depuis le déclenchement de la
guerre ou comment prendre l'art plutôt
que les armes en résidence au mans
depuis plus d'un mois il prépare
actuellement un spectacle qui raconte
leur histoire un sujet nellen galiana
pour ahlem tv sarthe
au début c'est joyeux c'est la vie
d'avant puis rapidement tout sombre et
les artistes qui racontent la guerre les
bombardements les viols les vols puis la
fuite
le pape l'ukrainien est plus uni que
jamais et c'est la chose la plus
importante est finalement c'est ce que
poutine a réussi de mieux il a réussi à
unir les gens du monde entier
leur idée faire front à travers l'art
elles ont été accueillies début mars par
le théâtre du préau de vire dans un
premier temps elle n'était pas du tout
prête à partir du cren de sa sous le
choc d'une part et puis ensuite elle
voulait rester au pays trouver un moyen
de lutter sur place et en fait ça a été
notre axe et qu'on leur a dit que pour
lutter
étant donné qu'elle est artiste il
fallait qu'elle était un outil de
travail et c'est là où on s'est mis
surtout en état de marche c'est qu'on
leur a proposé un outil de travail et
des moyens pour créer prochainement la
troupe entamera une tournée elles seront
de passage au mans pour quinconces où 17
juin
[Musique]
c'est une entreprise au succès fulgurant
qui n'a pas fini de grandir l'entreprise
bio l'a implanté en moselle développe un
procédé unique en son genre la
décontamination d'objets par uv avec un
taux d'éradication des virus et
bactéries de plus de 99% la chasse aux
qu'ovide 19 est donc lancée grâce à des
machines innovantes et performantes
quelques minutes suffisent pour une
désinfection totale
explication des mafate shetty pour
moselle théréau regarder sous vos yeux
le tout premier prototype de quais sont
des contaminants de bio la sortie en
2020 depuis cet autre modèle ou vu le
jour je m'appelle lunettes hop je vais
vers l'intérieur
et les lunettes le temps de quelques
instants sont parfaitement décontaminer
celui ci en bois massif est le plus
petit sa cible principale les hôtels
aujourd'hui dans les hôtels quand vous
rendez votre paie on remet la clé dans
une petite boîte ya aucune des
infections sceptiques parfaitement
comment on change d'échelle avec sept
autres box
elle est comme toutes les autres équipes
et de l'anc wc à 360° une technologie
éradiquant l'ensemble des virus et
bactéries en seulement quelques secondes
c'est comme si on mettait un coup de
soleil aux bactéries dans les uv vous
avez des uv à kiki et le soleil les uvb
les uv cesser les cds plus nocifs il se
rapproche des rayons x et donc nous on
utilise la technologie uv c pour
détruire les bacs tél l'autre intérêt et
la pièce d'humidité facteur important
pour certains objets tout ce qui est
nettoyage dans les cra chine étoile
avait sali nettoie en 30 ans ils peuvent
plus ils ont enlevé certains jouets tous
les jouets en bois les potes parce
qu'ils pouvaient plus de nettoyer enfin
monte ou encore d'un cran ceux qui sont
en toile est conçu pour accueillir des
fauteuils roulants en quelques mois
viola a changé d'échelle elle a
notamment remporté le prix de meilleure
start up du grand test dans la catégorie
jeunes pousses aujourd'hui ils sont une
petite douzaine à travailler sur ces
système de décontamination
si 2025 l'objectif est d'embaucher une
cinquantaine de salariés
de bonnes perspectives économiques le
metaverse en a lui aussi aujourd'hui
vous connaissez les réseaux sociaux et
sites internet ou les jeux vidéo et bien
maintenant tout cela peut se retrouver
dans un même univers virtuel le
metaverse un monde parallèle en 3d aux
multiples applications et dans cette
fiction qui est en train de devenir
réalité la principauté de monaco entend
bien jouer les premiers rôles elle
s'apprête à accueillir un grand forum
sur le sujet
avantage de christophe rigaud regarder
lorsque le monde de la 3d rencontre
celui de l'internet bienvenue dans le
métavers ce un univers parallèle fait
deux mondes virtuels pendant deux jours
la principauté de monaco va réunir les
acteurs les plus importants de cette
nouvelle technologie pendant le méta
entertainment world une occasion de
mieux comprendre cet univers on va se
digitalise est entièrement nos vêtements
nos voitures nos maisons et tout ça va
vivre dans un environnement qui va être
digital donc à travers des écrans à
travers des lunettes qui si on vulgarise
un petit peu est un jeu vidéo mais avec
une ambition
financière et de marché d'opportunités
beaucoup plus grande qu'un simple jeu
vidéo les marques de luxe et les grandes
entreprises ont bien compris toutes les
applications qu'offre ce nouveau monde
digital
tout va venir dans une manière 3
dimensionnelle là
le shopping par exemple on va avoir des
options d amazon mais plus grande qu'on
peut toucher les produits on peut
laisser on peut faire tous intense une
hamas en 3d par exemple
le métavers ce pourrait également offrir
de véritables expériences immersives
pour les films et les séries ils vont
sentir avec des vestes qui va apporter
une sensation quand tu vas voir
quelqu'un en train d'embrasser quelqu'un
ou le faire une une bagarre chaque fois
que comédien se reçoit un cac vous le
sentirez le metaverse se retrouvera
jusque dans la construction de nos
villes ça n'a tout métamorphosé alors
principalement urbanisme et architecture
vont être atteints par le métal earth
par rapport à la conception mais
également par rapport à la gestion
technique des bâtiments donc ce qui faut
noter également à ce niveau là sans les
outils de communication qui vont être
complétés complémenter entre architectes
ingénieurs consultants technicien
pratique du bâtiment par l'industrie met
adverse
le méthane time in the world se
déroulera les 23 et 24 mai à l'hôtel
hermitage de monaco
comme les océans les forêts subiste elle
aussi les conséquences du réchauffement
climatique
plusieurs espèces d'arbres sont
notamment menacées par la hausse des
températures et l'apparition de nouveaux
parasites pour les préserver des
campagnes de ramassage de graines sont
organisées pour les replanter ensuite
parmi les arbres protégés en picardie
l'orne lice jérôme houbron journalistes
web tv nous emmène en forêt de compiègne
à la découverte de cet arbre et de ceux
qui travaillent à sa sauvegarde regarder
quand vous voyez une marque comme ça sur
l'arbre
ça c'est à dire que c'est leur muse
c'est un peu une mission sauvetage en
pleine forêt de compiègne une mission au
secours de leurs milices c'est cette
espèce rare d'arbres connu de la région
et dont la population ne cesse de
diminuer pour en préserver l'essence
l'office national des forêts et le
conservatoire botanique de bailleul
lancé un plan de sauvegarde objectif
reboiser les forêts picarde l'idée c'est
que ces plans nous sert dans nos projets
de reconstitution et d'enrichissement
alors notamment sur les parcelles qu'ont
pu être impacté récemment par rapport à
des problématiques de dépérissement que
l'on a en forêt et l'idée c'est de
reconstituer des secteurs de forêt ou
ces essences ne sont pas présentes pour
pouvoir aussi avoir cet aspect
préservation de l'espèce les forêt de
laigue chiry ourscamp et compiègne et ne
compte que quelques centaines d'ormeaux
lice et pour cause son habitat forestier
et humide disparaît alors dans les
feuillages à même le sol les élèves du
lycée agricole des rayons sont chargés
de collecter les précieuses graines que
l'arbre libère au printemps je veux
juste repérer les bonnes graines et
regarder s'il ya du duvet dessus c'est
une identification né dans une formation
où on apprend à le faire donc on en sait
aller au détail pour pour les heures
pour les identifier pas facile de
reconnaître un arbre parmi tant d'autres
heureusement leur mélissa quelques
particularités on voit en bordure de ces
samar des petits s'il blanchâtre c'est
typique de l'espèce et ensuite sur des
sujets plus développés on a la présence
de contrefort sur la partie inférieure
de l'arbre et ça c'est vraiment une
caractéristique de dos les sens
une fois triés et séchez les milliers de
graines prélevés seront mises en culture
par le lycée horticole de ribécourt
premières plantations prévue en fin
d'année
en famille entre amis vous en ferez
c'est sur cet été des barbecues ce mode
de cuisson star des grandes vacances et
gay les repas des français avec le
retour du soleil en gironde le barbecue
s'invite désormais sur l'eau grâce au
bateau barbecue c'est son nom le
principe est simple louer un bateau sans
permis et faire un ses grillades en
naviguant sur l'eau un reportage près de
libourne d'yvan branchies pour la
rédaction de télé 7 la chaîne du groupe
sud ouest
al'approche de l'été toujours le même
dilemme une balade en bateau ou un
barbecue entre amis un conflit que le
moulin de porchères a peut être réglé
avec sa nouvelle activité un bateau
électrique en forme de donuts équipé
d'un barbecue à gaz qui file jusqu'à 10
kilomètres par heure au beau milieu de
la rivière riscle on est au sein de la
zone natura 2000 de liste et au sein
également du périmètre man and biosphère
donc réserve mondiale de biosphère
classé par l'unesco et donc c'est
vraiment une parenthèse de calme or
civilisation quasiment une embarcation
de 2h30 où les convives ne se préoccupe
de rien grillades boissons vaisselle le
moulin s'occupe de tout lancé l'année
dernière près de 85 mille euros ont été
investis pour quatre bateaux de 6 et 10
places le prix de l'attractivité selon
le maire de libourne nous développons
des activités atypique le territoire du
libournais de la kali c'est un
territoire intérieur de la gironde et
plus renée éloignés de la mer plus faute
malin pour faire venir des visiteurs
avec le retour tant attendu d'une saison
à la normale et des touristes étrangers
le moulin espère attirer 4000 visiteurs
cet été sur ces bateaux prix de
l'excursion environ 40 euros par
personne
et bon appétit bien sûr si vous êtes à
table chez vous ou sur l'eau des balades
à vélo sont aussi certainement au
programme de vos vacances et pour
sensibiliser les populations et
notamment les automobilistes au partage
de la route une association corse a
entrepris un tour de l'île à vélo des
jeunes âgés de 14 à 20 ans ont parcouru
180 km en quatre jours une performance
pour la prévention routière images et
réactions récoltées par franck offerte
chez ti et dylan rollos de la rédaction
de via télé pas aisée en corse ce sont
des jeunes qui ne sont pas forcément
cycliste ce sont des jeunes qui conte a
entraîné en amont et eu en fait ils vont
devenir les nouveaux ambassadeurs de la
route donc à charge à eux d'être des
vrais ambassadeurs dans leur quartier au
niveau de la sécurité que ce soit à vélo
un moto en voiture pour les ja nous
permis ce sont nos ambassadeurs de la
route je pense que il faut aussi que les
cyclistes se montre bien visuellement
faut pas hésiter en fait à mettre une
chasuble il ya beaucoup de cyclistes qui
ont pas de moyens rétro-réfléchissant le
port du casque 11 encore trop de
cyclistes que deux qui ont pas le casque
et c'est pareil faut aussi que les
conducteurs partagent la route la route
n'appartient pas en fait qu aux
automobilistes de la selle du vélo au
dos de cheval dans ce grand jt des
territoires découvrons à présent
l'action d'une association en faveur des
jeunes issus des quartiers défavorisés
dans les yvelines l'égalité des chances
passe par la pratique d'activités
réservée habituellement à des publics
aisés prendre confiance à cheval c'est
possible pour tous comme nous le prouve
c'est au portage de mathilde francou
pour tv 78 la chaîne des yvelines cela
fait deux ans que hassiane nourine et ça
aux scènes peuvent fouler la piste et
pratiquer leur passion grâce à la
fondation gouesnac'h us et l'association
chante l'ouvèze fraternité pour
l'égalité des chances une soixantaine de
jeunes accèdent à des sports comme le
golf le tennis et l'équitation moi je
suis
d'abord une habitante de champions
league depuis 31 ans mère célibataire
avec trois enfants trois garçons je
connais un peu la situation des enfants
des quartiers il y avait un besoin ou
non
signalée vers six jeunes là il d'en
parler d'autre chose de sortir aussi de
l'or
de leur domaine leur quartier quoi ces
activités sportives sont essentiels au
développement et à l'épanouissement de
l'enfant elle peut parfois coûter très
cher alors pour que la pratique sportive
soit équitable la fondation guen à russe
soutient financièrement les familles
finalement c'était mon rêve de faire
équitation et c'était très cher donc
avant je pouvais pas on a fait une année
et la deuxième année on pouvait pas et
mais j'ai quand même fait et j'aime
beaucoup le contact avec le cheval qu'on
a quand le brosse qu'on est sur son dos
qui n'allait coûte outre les acquis
sportif l'équitation permet également
aux jeunes de sortir de leur zone de
confort et d'évoluer au sein de la
société - l'évolution je la vois surtout
sur leur comportement
le leur
l'ours acquis techniques c'est autre
chose mais c'est surtout leur
comportement parce que certains enfants
n'ont pas de cadre familial alors
certains sont bien cadré d'autres noms
sont pas assez cadré donc on arrive ici
nous on fait un peu la police et un
petit peu géré on fait un peu office
d'éducateurs quoi de plus en plus
l'association tresques ouvre son champ
de compétences à des activités
culturelles comme des ateliers d'arts
plastiques de théâtre ou encore de chant
elle anime également des cours pour
apprendre le français et le numérique
aux parents qui le souhaitent voilà le
mois de mai est traditionnellement un
mois de transhumance pour les éleveurs
de montagne on vous propose de suivre ce
moment qui marque le rythme des saisons
auprès des vaches vosgiennes une race
qui a bien failli disparaître mais qui
reprend des couleurs depuis quelques
années elle permet notamment de produire
le fameux monster un fromage sellem en
france reportage lors de l'ascension
d'un troupeau avec marie danielle
rogowicz et les apu requis et de vosges
télévision
les vaches qui arborait les cloches des
grands jours prête pour leur
transhumance d'été un rendez vous festif
qui attire toujours du monde et qu'ils
viennent des vosges ou d'ailleurs
connaisseurs ou curieux ils étaient
impatients de vivre cette tradition
ancestrale tout à fait par hasard ce
matin on est allé au marché de gérardmer
il veut aussi qu'ils vendaient du
fromage nous a dit qu'il y avait une
transhumance c'est super on c'est la
première fois qu'on vient on avait su on
avait jamais le temps maintenant que
furent traités j'en profite qu'est ce
qui vous plaît dans la transhumance la
tradition la tradition des tec les bêtes
la nature et toutes ces choses qui se
perdent et pour se mettre dans
l'ambiance les marcheurs ont profité
d'un instant musical au son du cor des
alpes
[Musique]
donc on fait quelques provisions de
produits de la ferme les gens qui
connaissent pas ils viennent découvrir
et puis les habitués ouais ils viennent
chercher leur du master leurs petits
morceaux de tom c'est pour prendre des
forces pour la montée exactement
exactement parce qu'il va falloir être
au niveau des vaches donc parfois est en
forme et le saviez vous la liqueur de
génépi local c'est aussi bon pour les
vedettes du jour ça c'est pour les
vaches pour les aider à remonter en fait
nous on est en forme on n'a pas besoin
mais elle en a un petit peu de réconfort
et de
relier ses congénères ont donné le signe
du départ et c'est à une bonne allure
qu'elles ont pris la route pour quelques
kilomètres vers les estives l'occasion
d'admirer les paysages du massif vosgien
la transhumance pour la famille vers ce
verre c'est bien plus qu'une carte
postale c'est avant tout un événement à
partager ça fait partie de notre
patrimoine donc on veut partager sa nou
avec les amis les visiteurs tout
simplement et aussi la famille puis
transmettre à nos enfants pour que ça
continue
c'est aussi une façon de travailler pour
nous éleveurs on en bonne partie de
l'année quand on monte en haut ça permet
aux prés de fauche dans bada de récolter
du foin pour l'hiver donc d'être
autonome après au niveau du froid
mais il était déjà temps de repartir
pour les vosgiennes qui resteront sur
les chaumes avant de redescendre à
l'automne
[Musique]
voilà un bon été à elle bien sûr
direction la martinique maintenant pour
terminer cette édition où la ville de
saint-pierre commémorant ce moment
l'éruption de la montagne pelée en 1902
la catastrophe a fait à l'époque plus de
30000 morts et a suscité l'attention
médiatique du monde entier c'est le
thème d'une exposition proposée par une
association locale à travers la
présentation de coupures de presse
d'époque une remontée dans le temps avec
jean-marc d'abreu pour vyas atv
martinique sur place
le 11 mai 1902 ce journal américain
accor sa une à l'effroyable et l'option
de la montagne pelée il titre st pierre
un bûcher funéraire ardent le 25 mai à
rome l'hebdomadaire italien 'la tribune'
à illustrate à publie cette illustration
du cataclysme le malheur des pierrotin
fera durant des semaines à une donatrice
internationaux éruption volcanique à la
martinique un télégramme du gouverneur
de la martinique daté du 4 mai 1902
vient de faire savoir au ministre des
colonies qu'une éruption du volcan de la
montagne pelée s'était produite dans la
nuit du 3 au 4 mai voilà un premier
article du premier journal la justice
qui relate les prémices la de l'option
de la montagne palais les originaux
constitue des pièces importantes de
l'exposition
400 parution de presse ont réuni à 20
dont la moitié provient de la collection
privée de la famille de ce sont des
journaux
qui parle de la martinique je précise
bien des journaux de france
métropolitaine ou de l'étranger qui
parle de la martinique ça c'est juste
par par passion
alors je les ai trouvés
dans des foires dans des marchés
spécialisés sur des sites spécialisés
ces articles ne laisse pas indifférent
les visiteurs se sont pas mal
d'informations dont on ne disposait pas
donc la vue l'éruption à travers les
médias internationaux là
je ne savais pas que j'allais de
découvrir
l'exposition met aussi en lumière les
travers du journalisme de l'époque ces
illustrations décrivant le chaos pour
vendre de la feuille de chou des
articles de presse d'extrême droite et
cette une du petit journée pour la
france on a aussi une politisation avec
une mise en scène
patriotique exacerbé où on voit cette
france qui vient sauver une martinique
forcément indolente à travers l'image
d'une créole qui est à ses pieds et qui
regardent en fleurs
sa martinique
mes trucs les oeuvres sont visibles
durant le mois de mai à la maison de la
bourse de saint pierre mais aussi dans
quatre lieux de la côte
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci d'avoir suivi cette
édition on se retrouve très vite à
bientôt au revoir
[Musique]